all right you know what why not here we
go I'm about to release of information
that's never been sold before so I got
her
Neil Lane wasn't there anybody I put a
ring on it
hi guys how are you I'm real good I just
noticed Geller you were in a KP necklace
so a brand just sent me this necklace
and I had my girlfriend
I couldn't get my mail forever because I
wasn't back in Chicago but she brought
it for me I was like this is the cutest
thing
it's so cute well I this is such a good
note to start out on because you know
the biggest question I have for you guys
is just how happy are you why is this
working so well because not only did you
guys come off of a reality show find a
way to each other then you get thrown
into a pandemic you're probably spending
tons of time together and then apart
when Peters working like what's working
about this we've truly spent probably
every single day with each other
I think that's which has shown us that
this is working it's super just natural
and organic we have not gotten sick to
each other okay that's a huge awesome
sign it's kind of cool I hung out with
her for like almost four months and I'm
still not over yeah I miss Lauren it's
like it's fun because we just get along
we're on the same page as everything um
he motivates me to do a lot I motivate
him to do a lot and it's like we're like
best friends pushing each other forward
to like better each other and I feel
like I I have I have a little bit more
of a softer side and you have a little
bit more the harder side a little bit of
quicks and like she'll be stronger and I
like soften her up a little bit the way
we all sort of found out that Peter and
Kelly were a thing was like those photos
in Chicago and she's slung over the back
and it all happened I actually told
Peter not to come to Chicago in the ass
at first I was just like no and it's not
it's not anything against him it just
sometimes it's not it kind of sucks
being in the spotlight because him and I
were just hanging out as friends truly
at that point in time and you I kind of
had something in my head being like oh
my god if I'm seen with him then things
are gonna spark which happened but it
sucks to be in the spotlight sometimes
because I enjoyed him as a friend at
that point in time and there would have
been nice to have him here and my head
was just telling me no for PR reasons
and then I was like you know what I
gotta stop caring about that so much
yes like come out like please come out
like his offer still on the table like
come see me who made the first move how
did this transition like what is it you
Peter you why did you want to go to
Chicago I need the the love story now
Laura we met up I officially got her
number and then she had to leave back to
Chicago if we just kept texting and then
I remember I'm on my couch just watching
TV and we're talking like I just had
this idea like hey like let me come out
and spend some time with you and you
always been there for me let me return
the favor
she said no and I was like really bummed
about that I remember going to bed and
then I woke up and I got a text like is
the offer still on the table and then I
hopped on uh I remember I looked on my
my dad's passes cuz bill doesn't fly
directly to Chicago from LA so I hopped
on a United flight on my dad's passes
next flight got out there and I loved it
though like you'd go back to LA and
without me and being like Joanna come
back even so I'm coming back like I'm
leaving Saturday I'll be back Tuesday I
was like okay I love seeing how happy
you guys are I saw one quick moment
where it looked like Peter you were
giving her some kind of big rose in one
of the videos what was that Bernadette
my neighbors are big fans of the show so
they found out we're down there and they
brought him over and they're like you
for this I had to give her the final
rose so that was he making up for it
Kelly now has the final rose yeah I
compensate it was very large hazarded
are we in love I don't know how I told
her I loved it for the first time yes
yeah so I got her Neil Lane wasn't there
right now but I got her this little
gumball machine during and we're having
a cool dad and I took her back instead
actually I said on the couch that you
told me not to come to Chicago on
on me out but I took a that same couch
and I told her I want her to remember
this day from this gumball machine ring
is a day I told you that I love you and
was it there's always something about
Peter that I knew I just was like madly
in love like I just knew we would get
along and it's weird because I even told
him going on the show it's harder for
him to see because he didn't even really
like get to know me that well on the
show but like I saw a lot of like
compatibility things that added up
between him and I but he doesn't
necessarily know that he didn't know me
but like I saw him on Hannah Brown
season I saw him on just like news
articles and how his family dynamic is
and what he's interested in and all that
stuff and I was like wow he really adds
up for me but like it's hard to convey
that on the show to be like hey you and
I would really get along you did a
really good job not coming off weird but
yeah she did say that a lot like we just
we work like I see this working and I
wish I just wouldn't listen this is
pretty insane we're at the exact place
or I'm just randomly ran into Kelly
coming from an after-party for my high
school reunion she was coming back from
a wedding when you guys look at your
story
I mean you meeting each other at that
wedding and then where you are now
do you ever kind of play the mental game
of wait what if I just like walked away
with her at that wedding where would you
be now it's funny because this is
something that's said a lot like oh you
know I wish you would have just ran away
with Kelly when you first met her and
there was no point for you to be the
bachelor but I actually highly disagree
with that and I think that from going on
the show you learn a lot about yourself
you learn what you want what you don't
want you learn who to trust who not to
trust in like an everyday setting and
the thing I love about him is he does
have like such a pure heart but
sometimes that could be taken advantage
of and I think that coming off of this
show he has learned so much I have
learned so much but it like works for us
now I think we both through insane
amounts throughout the show if you have
the experience would've been amazing to
just start the relationship right there
it would have but things truly happen
furries
always you know believe in that and
we're very happy now so that's all
matters
well yeah Kelly you were the one telling
Peter on camera
Peter relationships don't have to be
hard not every relationship has to sit
here and be like jumping through hurdles
and super hard and all their stuff like
it can be easy and so it could be fun
Peter wait did you have to learn that I
mean do you feel like you kind of if you
look back do you think wow maybe I went
on the show I learned that and then that
experience kind of made me ready for
this relationship I think there's some
truth that for sure I think on the show
I was a little bit I was caught up I was
a little in over my head I was there
definitely was some you know confliction
and confusion for me just because I
again I was giving so much of myself to
every single relationship I was trying
to know his game so invested that I
think I almost lost sight of really what
just a beautiful good relationship can
be Peter your finale I mean Kelly was in
the audience that happened craziest
thing like that I think about that all
the time like that should I could
craziest thing to me I know Kelly what
was going through your mind that night
do you think you could have ever told
that woman and would she have believed
that you two would be together now just
sitting there like watching it all like
go down and that's the only that's the
only thought that I had I was like wow
this is there's a lot of drama going
down if you want to be with a woman you
need to become a real man Peter what was
your headspace then versus now you know
I don't even know if you guys watched
that finale did you ever watch it back
just a little bit but honestly not I
haven't watched it again since well how
do you compare those two Peters and
those two Kelley's oh my god I yeah
complete 180 the guy I truly am in such
just a good place just so confident in
this relationship and you know just so
truly thankful for I can't
I truly I remember like that feeling
that night and I was a tough night for
so so many of us and never would have
imagined having this happiness just a
couple months later with Kelly I
remember interviewing Kelly I think the
night after your finale um and she said
well barb was wanting to talk to me at
the finale she said I'm your biggest fan
Barb's a huge fan she stands Kelly barb
loves Kelly we know this we've seen the
cheers give me a cake barb like get her
number Peter you know my mom was 100%
always a hundred percent supporter about
that when she found out I got her number
she was like you could see she was
cheering on all right you know what why
not here we go I'm about to release some
information that's never been sold
before because it was actually not bad
stuff but this is actually kind of funny
so I remember being in the band going to
the hospital in Costa Rica when I split
my forehead open I had to call my mom
because I knew that if anything got out
before she heard from me she was gonna
freak actually didn't gonna next flight
out there we go serega so I'm calling
her and you know I'm trying to talk to
her and she's like I can tell she's
trying to like well after she found out
that my head was okay and we're all good
she was trying to like give me hints of
a coup she like who she liked and she
kept saying I'm you know this that then
me let me see that
from Chicago that's what she was saying
she was giving me hints on the phone
that she liked Kelly and I liked the
girl from my city yeah flip them in
there and yeah so that's how far back
that that love I guess for Kelly goes
yeah it's a little little bit
information that nobody knows I think
your mom might be the person who
invented the phrase mother knows best
how hard was that for your mom I don't
know how much you've talked to Barb
about you know I know she was saying
pick Hannah Ann and obviously she she
did not thank you and Madison were a
good fit everyone that knows him knows
that it's it's not you know it's not
gonna work so how hard was that for her
when she'd been into Kelly this whole
time like do you think she was genuinely
into you being with Hannah
was it kind of all a struggle for her at
that point no she she definitely fell in
love with him and all those feelings
were very very genuine and again just
like this is just this is more of a
junkie she was just it was a quick thing
we felt like it was kind of funny how
did she react when you sent Kelly home
gonna watch that episode yet and she and
she won't watch it that's that's not
happening honestly I don't I thought
about it I could video at this point
like I don't it doesn't really bother me
bothers me I couldn't watch it that's
why tell me I just I feel like I'd be a
wreck like an absolute mess cuz I
actually yeah I remember that vividly
too I remember walking into that car and
like something's still just I look back
on that did not feel right and that
sounds so cliche I don't think I've ever
even fluckey that but it just like I I
remember like holding her hands and like
looking in her eyes and just like her
look I did it just like it didn't feel
right Kel when you look back on your
time on the show are you kind of a
little blown away that you were even on
a reality show with the personality but
you have for sure a thousand percent
like it's just there's a lot of things
that I just don't think would translate
well on a reality show um and and that's
fine there's nothing wrong with that
it's not like but I definitely struggled
I'm not like regretting it I don't
regret going on the show in any way I'm
like the biggest bachelor fan at work
and I always will be but I feel like
while just from history you've seen some
relationships through the show it works
and you get your real life it doesn't
work just because of the relation should
be in romanticized and just all that
comes with being on the show it's
amazing for us it's been the exact
opposite for whatever reason we just
didn't really get to know each other
super bail on the show it was it our cup
of tea but in real life
after it's just been it's been seamless
and it's just how different would things
have been if you'd kept Kelly on the
show I mean Kelly you weren't like
thriving do you think you would have
stayed the whole time I talked to Peter
about this all the time there's some
things that like I don't know how I
handle a lot of different things like
even strip fantasy suite week like I
probably would have maybe felt awkward
you know
so who knows how my head would have been
or what I would have done then I feel
like if I would have kept her for
hometown's like it would it would have
been us yet I would have met her family
for brothers
exactly like I said him like he's told
me that before and I was like Peter to
be completely honest like I was able to
give you a heads up and like give you a
description on each brother my sister my
parents like don't take this to heart
they'll probably make like rude comments
but like just just brush it off like oh
that's a lot of my family they're very
outspoken there's so many of them like
he would have probably walked in that
house but it's a strange dynamic her mom
is absolutely amazing her and Barb oh my
god those two you've got those two
Chicago gals them both don't have a
builder oh my god we need to get your
mom on TV Barb and your mom next to each
other in an audience I honestly am like
I'm so disappointed because like the
rule they get to meet your mom what has
she said about Peter and this
relationship does the Flanagan family
approved he actually loves him and like
in to the point where like I have to
like almost make fun of her like when
Peter comes around and she's on
speakerphone for like boys it's
hilarious
what was kind of the biggest thing the
most important thing to talk about that
you worked through that got you here now
Peter was like convinced that I didn't
even like him maybe why I wonder what
I'll be nothing here seen a bit
you know my personality is very
laid-back I'm not really into the drama
so that's one thing but he took that as
like she's just here for vacation she
doesn't care about me and that wasn't
the case it was just like when I'm not
seeing him I'm gonna chill so I think
that was the first conversation we had
what seems like did you even like me and
I was like of course I did
and then just kind of explained like now
that he's gone to know my personality it
makes a lot more sense but back then he
didn't really understand any of it I
think talk for us is or has been tough
we've been doing really good with it
moving forward it's just like you know
people like to say oh she wasn't your
first choice and I know for Kellis been
tough to see listen at the end of the
day this is a it's a reality TV dating
show this is not real life normal life
so I don't know just gonna done a good
job of just you know reassuring each
other and just explaining why I did
things Wade it and owning up to my
faults and and just being a better
person as a board I do have to have a
little bit of understanding because you
come off the finale and and you're with
Madison and then I think it was either
24 or 48 hours later you guys were done
what was that turnaround what what went
down I know they say oh it's 24-48 hours
that was the shortest relationship ever
we never committed to a relationship we
were just gonna talk things through and
that's what occurred you know in the
next couple of days and we went our own
separate ways and you know I know I
don't look back she doesn't look back
but I think some people lose they think
that we got back together we never were
back together where are you guys at
right now with with Madison with Hanna
Ann cuz Kelly I know that you'd been
friendly with them and there was a
little bit of social media stuff where I
think Madison had made some comments and
Peter you said you know there's more to
this story so what was the more to the
story I was I was actually really close
with both girls on the show coming off
the show it's actually funny because the
girls that you are like very close with
on the show aren't necessarily all the
girls that you're like extremely close
with off the show I have no ill will
towards Madison I think she's a great
girl
it's just this whole the whole situation
is like off words it was an awkward
weird situation that we were all going
through and yeah we
signed up for it so we had to live
through it but truly no ill-will towards
anyone I want the best of them of course
not saying same thing goes for Han Han a
hundred percent so yeah I was texting
with Han and the other day like her and
I did you shoot him a text before you
guys went official or was it like it's
just happening I was in communication
with Hanna and because her and I her and
I were texting and I just said I gave
her a call and told her exactly what
happened she said that's fine she's like
I thank you so much for calling me I
really respect you and our friendship
Peter like when you do look back both
choosing Hanna Anne and then trying
things again with Madison like what was
that headspace where were you at and
what was driving those decisions
especially as you look at how happy you
are now by having made different
decisions I was confused I was very
confused and I'm not ashamed to admit
that at all I you know I've said this a
couple of times I almost feel like it
would have been odd if I wasn't confused
you know going through that many
relationships in such a short amount of
time it's super tough The Bachelor was
an amazing experience that we'll never
forget
and always use so grateful for but
really mess up II really really messed
me and it was the hardest thing I've
ever done in my entire life I could do
it again and guarantee she was gonna be
there I would do it so differently oh my
god you have no idea I know everyone's
called me a people pleaser in this and
you need some great that's do you think
yes and you guys are right 100% I am a
new man in that regard I promise you but
I don't know just with Kelly it just I
literally it sounds so cliche I can just
be myself
she truly like she gets me and she's my
biggest fan and she supports me and
she's always there for me and she you
know I I know I have my partner in crime
forever and like I I don't know I just
I've never had this confidence from a
relationship I do I do acknowledge it I
have grown a lot but I'm not saying it's
all on me either it's hurt like it's
truly Kelly and just like she is I truly
believe the perfect person for me and I
feel so blessed
I mean that well Kelly was there a
period where he did have to gain trust
back with you or anything like that
because he had sent you home and you'd
seen him do these other things and
finish out the show in other ways yeah
for sure I mean that's every
relationship like Trust is a huge thing
but if you just hear each other out it's
a lot easier there's a lot of things
that goes on that many people don't know
and how a lot of things actually panned
out you know no one really knows that
but we've sat down and like talk
everything through and it makes a lot
more sense if you're on our and then the
public's and I'm still working to make
it up to her for not picking her and I'm
never gonna stop so you guys is ending
nobody saw coming no I know people like
for some reason refused to believe that
I wasn't gonna be with Peter throughout
everything that happened like there's so
many people that I meet that really I
still knew even when you went home that
it was gonna be you guys and I was like
how final is this like are you guys
moving in together I think you're at
Kelly's apartment Chicago right now
what's the plan what is a year from now
look like yeah we are Kelly's party
right now we uh we do want to move in
with each other hopefully New York City
early fall maybe like September late
summer we love to live in New York City
and yeah this is this is very serious
obviously plan
there's jumping right into it do you
guys talk about things like marriage and
kids and stuff like that you have those
discussions we talk about it openly like
oh when we're this age or something like
that like even moving and moving in
together New York's like a big deal you
know and we definitely talk as if like
it's long term like it's not going
anywhere and I think that just it's
totally fine with us again
we're not on a reality show anymore we
could take time like we don't need to
brush anything I'm gonna make sure like
each other's in the right headspace and
there's nothing wrong with that we're
happy and really being like honestly
just by going on the show it's kind of
like pushing me to go slower if anything
instead of like I don't absolutely not
right I'm super excited to take this
next step with Kel and move to New York
and just see what adventures await and
you know we have so many dreams together
to just travel and obviously travel is
one of our biggest passions together the
world's at a weird halt and stop and go
right now with the pandemic but you guys
have shared some of this travel content
how much do you see that being part of
your futures and your careers will you
like devote full time to that are you
gonna keep flying and and being the
legal eagle what's the plan he's always
he's never I'm currently still working
it's super super slow our office is
actually still closed down so that's why
everyone's working remotely and we
figured out that working remotely is
actually a lot easier than men doing
stuff on the side with him so I don't
necessarily need to be in the office and
you know gives a lot of days off when he
flies so the whole travel thing just
works perfect for our schedule and right
now it's I mean it's really it's it's
really sad obviously what's going on the
airline industry's been you know
devastated as everyone knows so I'm
actually not even flying right now most
likely until hopefully October hopefully
there's no furloughs for the pilot group
class so staying positive and there is a
recovery but yeah I plan on doing that
you know so I have to retire on the side
though I really were both really excited
to kind of yeah we want to spin the
globe like we call it and just go and
share our passion around me you know all
this amazing spots around the world and
do it together and just let people yeah
look kind of vicariously through those
videos if they want and would you guys
want to do not just more videos but a
show and would you do a travel reality
show or are you a little gun-shy about
reality - I don't think you realize how
awkward I
Sam when like cameras come out like a
video even when people stop us in public
I'm like behind his back hiding
everything love to have a reality show
just following Kelly wrong around see
how awkward she gets in public it's
absolutely hilarious I don't like when
there's so much attention on me like
when when people are like oh my god and
like the whole room is on me I don't
feel comfortable I want to ask you guys
to about your your thoughts for Claire
Claire season is starting next she's
gonna be doing it all with a pandemic in
mind how could you guys see the show
potentially changing with that I think
it's gonna be a massive difference I
think the first thing is the age I think
that there's gonna be a lot less drama
according to you know the contestants
coming in and you're a little bit older
things that are important to you when
you're 24 versus 40 are completely
different before um and I think that you
care less about little things and the
bigger picture is more in mind because
of the pandemic Delaine things everyone
knows who the Bachelorette is and so
that's only to her benefit you know only
bring out hopefully you know men that
are really really you know actually
there for her and so I think this has
the potential to be an amazing season
personally I think it might be a little
bit different going on a show like this
you get so many endorphins going on
these like lavish dates and these really
crazy dates and when you're with someone
it makes you fun with them better just
because you guys are doing something so
out of the ordinary and something so out
of your regular day life that it like
almost convinces you to fall in love
with that person even if you're not as
compatible so again going on Clair
season the fact that they're not gonna
be able to do these lavish dates and
stuff like that those who do latter
stage those fish dish but they can't
like leave a resort yeah I mean I don't
know maybe if this is my guess if they
can't leave a resort I think it's gonna
be more focused on are we compatible
instead of like oh my god look at how
amazing this mountain is and I really I
think for sure and I'm really excited
for it I think it's gonna be an amazing
love story and it's gonna get back to
that and I'm so excited for that Peter
you had a wild ride it's in advance but
what advice do you have for who we
already know to be our new bachelor
matching
now James yeah I uh I'm very I haven't
met him actually I just reached out on
Instagram but seems like an awesome guy
from what I've heard from Tyler just
make decisions for himself
nobody else don't try to please anyone
don't try to please you know the fans or
production or just do it for you and I
wish you know I would have taken my own
advice and done that on my season it's
so easy just to feel the pressure you
know from the show and again it's yeah
it's entertainment whatnot but it's also
it's your life more importantly and it's
your relationship it's potentially the
person you're gonna spend the rest your
life with and don't lose sight of that I
don't know if you've kept in touch with
Victoria fuller but were you surprised
to learn her and crystals are dating and
have you talked to her at all yes you
talk to her a little bit I think Elsie
was the one that set that up I think PLC
may have had a connection with Chris and
put them in contact and hey good for
them I think everything's great
everything's working out and I think
she's madly in love with him and good
for them no that makes me happy I really
like Chris I met him a couple of times a
really good deed so I'm really happy so
let's go over it she's wearing the
necklace by the way Peter how much do
you love that she wears that necklace oh
I'm happy if she wears this ring that
she hasn't taken this off yes look I was
gonna say you did end up putting a ring
on her finger
I did it wasn't the the finger I thought
it was going to be but yeah I I did so
what's in store it's like you guys kind
of got to work it's literally been
perfect like it's been unreal and I
wouldn't have it any other way honestly
to start the relationship
[Music]